hello everyone and welcome to game 11 of
the World Chess Championship match
between the animation
Ayan is still leading the match it's
five and a half to four and a half and
the ding is struggling to find ways of
how to bounce back we've had four
decisive games in a row but then it um
uh well the tempo became a bit slow so
let's see what happened in this one uh
the first move uh as uh we've done it
for every video so the first move was
made by this gentleman here it is a kind
of charlapa the chairman of the board
biotech National managing holding uh and
as you can see he's very very happy to
be there and to be making the first move
and I know some of you are saying that
it's silly to have the ceremonial move
being played by some by someone else but
at least I enjoy seeing that they are
happy doing it um so I I imagine they do
they do enjoy chess but that being said
let's check out the game so we again
have Pawn to E4 by nepo uh and the ding
goes for Ponte E5 which means we're
gonna have another real Lopez Knight of
three Knight to C6 Bishop to B5 uh the
rule Lopez is on the board and now not
Knight to F6 the Berlin defense ding
didn't really get anything in game nine
uh with the Berlin so he goes for
ponte's ex-morphy's defense and again
everyone's been asking the question will
we see a martial attack chances are we
will not because this thing who has to
come back in the match
and Jan hasn't really had any issues in
neutralizing things attempts with uh
with Ponte A6 so that why allow such a
such a crazy opening like the martial
attack that should pay for with Knight
to F6 uh castles in the bishop to E7 and
okay here if you uh would for example
have the Marshall then uh Rook D1 would
be played Rook D1 then C3 and then at
some point black strikes D5 and you have
the martial attack but here nepo just
plays D3 and that means no Marshall uh
for you uh good sir ding with B5 with
Bishop to B3 and now Pawn to D6 and now
uh the position is a very well known one
there are so many games in the database
and both nepo and ding had already this
position being even defeated Magnus
Carlsen uh with the black pieces from
this position uh he defeated him in St
Louis in 2019 and in that game C3 was
played and also interestingly nipple had
this position against the uh being
learned also In This World Series
championship match we've already seen it
in game five where C3 was played but
here we have pawned A3 Ponte for also a
very nice move but here we have Ponte A3
uh and now Knight to A5 uh here Nepal
already defeated the ding in this
position if you guys remember
uh in the candidates tournament in the
2020 candidates tournament uh castles
was played uh after Pawn day three was
made but here ding deviates from that
game he lost to Yan and he plays Knight
to A5 uh goes after the bishop Bishop to
A2 and only Now Pawn to C5 and uh
interestingly again not new territory
Jan nepomishi already had this position
with the white pieces against Magnus
Carlsen and interestingly ding had this
exact same position with the black uh
black pieces um against viswanathan
Anand so here at night the C3 with
Bishop to E6 and now Bishop to G5 just
nicely developing uh castles uh and here
Bishop captures and F6 there was there
was some talk of maybe Pawn to B4 first
and you should always check this move if
it's possible uh let's say Knight to C6
now you trade once captures captures and
now you trade captures on F6 Bishop
captures and now for example captures
and captures and the ding would be left
with a
uh doubled E Pawn but it's uh it doesn't
look like something that you can uh
forcefully uh lead into uh some Still
drawish Waters because well the Bishops
here the Knight has accessed the D4 The
Rook has the semi-openf file uh maybe
giving black too much uh to work with so
instead just Bishop captures an F4
Bishop captures and now Knight to D5
just uh playing very solid moves with G6
ding wants to move the bishop to G7 so
he doesn't have to worry about Knight
captures on F6 every move and a lot of
moves to consider here maybe a nice slow
C3 maybe B for now maybe you can capture
something uh here we have Queen to D2 uh
nepo it develops the queen he connects
his Rooks and also this uh signals that
he might be interested in a move like H4
because even though black is defending
ding is defending the H4 Square twice
he's not really because the queen also
has to keep an eye on the Knight on A5
so at some point ding will have to make
a move like Knight back to C6 and okay
Bishop to G7 and now again there is
again game that will reached this exact
same position uh last year uh Daniel
narodiski had it against Andrew tang and
he won a very nice game uh where he
started with Queen to G5 then F6 then
Queen back to E3 and so on and narodiski
won a very nice game but here we have
Knights the G5 by nipple uh and it is
now as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game
and again many choices for doing here
you could play King th8 maybe a sidestep
the the the bishop here you could play
Knight back to C6 as we've discussed
that's a fairly important move in pretty
much all of the lines you could play
Rook to A7 a nice defensive idea uh but
uh none of that was played with Pawn to
see for biting and this is sort of uh
asking uh it's not really even asking
for trouble it's just asking nepo uh are
you maybe interested in an early draw
here because it doesn't feel like uh
ding tries to achieve all that much here
with the black pieces uh maybe he will
look for his chances with uh with white
but the situation on the clock is Nepal
spent really no time here he has an hour
and 51 minutes on the clock uh and the
ding is down to one hour and 30 minutes
and okay uh we have Knight captures and
E6 nepo except the uh challenge F
characters and now Knight back to E3
with ideas of capturing and C4 Bishop to
H6 now stopping uh the knife removing
and The Rook 8 D1 again saying I just
want to capture on C4 and then pick up
the D6 pawn and now there are a couple
of moves to consider here one you could
play the a solo Rook the B8 you could
play Queen to B6 it's also a move that
was discussed quite a lot because okay
you you develop your queen to a nice
diagonal here the problem is there's
Knight captures on C4 and now you also
Target the bishop here and okay let's
see big captors on C4 Queen captures on
H6 Queen captures on B2 and not Bishop
captures and C4 Knight captures D
captures and queen captures an A3 it's a
equal material but it looks uh scary for
black for example Rogue D3 attacks the
queen and now okay you can't play Queen
before because Rook B3 to B7 but also if
you just move the queen to C5 something
like H4 can be played H5 it looks um
uh it looks fairly scary but okay it
should be okay like Rook 8 to B8 and now
you have to also worry about moves like
real captors and F2 followed by Rook to
B1 uh and so on uh so instead the ding
just went for this uh Rook to be that
we've discussed and now we have D
captures on C4 uh everyone thought okay
Yan would probably play something like
Queen to E2 just move out of The
Bishop's way or play H for even uh with
ideas of H5 because uh The Black Queen
still isn't covering that the Knight on
A5 would be hanging uh but nepo just
said uh I've had it with this game let's
just trade everything and by playing the
captors on C4 uh he started a capture
Fest that basically lasts for the rest
of the game look at this Knight captures
and C4 Bishop captures with B captures
and C for Queen captures and these six
Queen captures Rook captures and now
just Bishop captures on E3 everything
gets traded off the board F captures and
E3 uh Rook captures on F1 with check
King captures and now Rook captures on
B2 Rook captures and E6 Rook captures on
C2 Rook captures on A6 and now Rook the
A2 putting pressure on the A3 Pawn but
everything will just get traded off Rook
C6 Road captures an A3 Rook captures on
C4 and now Rook captures on E3 it's
equal material uh uh only a pair of
Rooks here so not much to look forward
to
uh King F2 we have rooked A3 Rook to C5
going after the pawn but it's not a
problem Rook day to check into a three
Rook uh King to three Rook day three
check King G4 Rook a two now going after
the Pawn King H3 rookie 2 and now Rook
captures on E5 nipple wins the pawn but
there's no way to hold on to it because
the king will contest The Rook here so
King F7 we have King G3 King to F6
attacks the rook and now just a rook to
E8 King F7 Rook to E5 king of six Rook
to E8 King F7 Rook to E5 and he was in
this position that the players uh sort
of agree to a robot is in fact drawn by
threefold repetition on move 39 uh they
even had to check with the with the
Arbiter because you can't offer a draw
before move 40 so they have to check if
it's okay to draw here you know by
threefold repetition uh but yeah it is
indeed a draw and not not a lot of
action in in game 11 of the world cheers
championship between uh
and uh one really does Wonder because
after those uh secret files from from
Dean's Camp
supposedly got leaked the the games
really slowed down in in in Tempo
because we've had like four decisive
games in a row and then you know
everything just gets countered
everything just gets taken into a
completely dry Shin game so it will be
very interesting to see uh what dings
Camp can come up with for he has two
more more wide games and how will he try
to bounce back in this match he has to
try something and you know if it comes
to
let's say one more game left he's gonna
have to try something really really wild
uh I can't even imagine what that will
be uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it we'll see if we'll have
some more action in the next one today
tomorrow is the rest day so if you have
any suggestions for me to cover is there
is no world Choice championship game to
cover that do use hashtag suggestion uh
so yeah I would like to thank Paul SAS
uh an anonymous person uh Simon ferner
Jordan Smith and Oscar Rodney for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreci appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the World Series
championship match until we have a new
world champion uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day